bonsoir à tous j'ai une très mauvaise
nouvelle à vous annoncer j'ai écouté RTL
ce matin
la cuisson à 19h00 c'est une partie
qu'on pourra réduire si on la décale un
peu et si on évite de faire marcher ces
quatre feux de sa plaque chauffante en
même temps à 19h00
on fait le point ce soir avec Adrien lac
alors Adrien et son nombreux les métiers
où il faut être bon en mathématiques oui
de plus en plus nombreux très pour cent
les emplois en France utilisent les
mathématiques vous l'avez dit c'est plus
de 3 millions de fiches de paye tous les
mois que faire pour les prix les
Français sont inquiets parce que il se
réveille d'un trop beau rêve
même en tenant compte mais malheureux
des pauvres des vieillards et des
déshérités en gros la vie française
était une vie de facilité et de bonheur
même si les Français ne rendaient pas
toujours cons
c'est la fin
centre-ville de Beyrouth
à visage découvert la braqueuse
revendique son acte
ça a l'air trop vite les yeux de Lyon à
la base en blanc
nous avons atteint le fond il y a deux
jours je suis allé voir le directeur de
la banque et je lui ai dit le temps nous
échappe ma sœur est malade elle va
mourir il m'a répondu qu'il ne pouvait
me donner que 200 dollars
[Musique]
aurait récupéré 13 des 20 000 euros
déposés par sa famille insuffisant
toutefois pour payer les soins de sa
sœur malade d'un cancer le traitement de
ma sœur c'est 50000 dollars
bien sûr aujourd'hui c'est un non sens
si on avait un président comme toi mais
ce serait pas la faillite déjà c'est dur
mais lui mais explique-toi bien tu sais
non gris la France a besoin d'être
dirigée par un chef d'entreprise oui et
je pense vraiment que tu n'es pas la
bonne personne
demain tous risé parions le feront parce
que les banques n'ont pas fait faillite
elles ont volé notre argent alors que la
monnaie a perdu près de 95% de sa valeur
le système bancaire cristallise la
colère du pays l'épargne des Libanais
est bloquée depuis trois ans les
retraits sont taxés et très limités 95%
de la population vit désormais sous le
seuil de pauvreté oui à la séquence du
stylo dites-vous Olivier Dartigues sur
Charles et c'est la manière de
fonctionner de Charles notamment et son
personnel
il y a cette fameuse phrase il n'y avait
jamais de grand homme pour son valet de
chambre
la baignoire doit être remplie à moitié
exactement et une eau tiède qui lui
mettent son dentifrice sur la brosse à
dents enfin moi je crois pas ça
déplacerait chez ses amis
chez ses amis pour un weekend à la
campagne avec son lit ses meubles mais
vous croyez ça
faisait transporter à chaque déplacement
sa lunette de toilette oui des exigences
commentées sur BFM par Roselyne Bachelot
qui ont le sang est revenu aux grosses
têtes et n'est plus le ministre de la
Culture et il emporte aussi ce son PQ
à 115 €, ça va et le t-shirt à 180
pardon
180 180
[Musique]
madame mais c'est t-shirt là dis donc
180 on peut payer 10 fois sans frais
180 et vous faites pas chier en même
temps il y a la qualité
j'ai pas l'habitude moi avec mon petit
salaire moi je m'achète pas des fringues
comme ça d'habitude mais là j'allais me
faire plaisir s'en fout ah bah oui tu
fais pas plaisir ma chérie tu as 400 €
pour te faire plaisir
tes plaisirs